as we've just seen the biden
administration
is sadly refusing to enforce the law at
the border but they're actually doing
the same thing within our nation as well
immigration and customs enforcement
better known as ice has been completely
handcuffed by the biden administration
for example ice deported fewer than 3
000 people last month
the lowest level on record according to
the washington post
which calls ice under biden an agency on
probation
biden also reportedly plans to cancel an
effort begun under president trump
that would have asked green card
applicants if they've ever been part of
a criminal gang
but u.s citizenship and immigration
services said late today in a statement
that they've made they've made no final
decisions about that form and that any
proposed changes will go through
appropriate procedures and as we've
mentioned earlier
biden's budget just released today
requests only a 0.1 percent funding
increase for the department of homeland
homeland security which includes ice by
the way the justice department only gets
a 5.6 percent increase while every other
department except defense and veterans
affairs
gets double-digit increases announcing
the budget today biden called it a
statement of values he should have
called it a statement of bankruptcy
apparently border security and law
enforcement aren't things he values
at all here with reaction arizona
congressman andy biggs and former senior
adviser to president trump
stephen miller stephen i'll you know
i'll go to you first i was just
listening to sarah's report and one of
the things that really disturbed me
about this
you remember when president trump
recovered from coronavirus um
and secret service agents who i knew i
worked there volunteered to take him in
the car so he could show the american
people he's okay and wave
and remember the media had an uproar
keep in mind they were all in protective
outfits
in protective garb they said oh my gosh
he's putting them in danger of
coronavirus
you know what's fascinating we have all
these border patrol agents now
documented cases of coronavirus people
who could be
could be killed by this and the media
all of a sudden you heard anything about
that stephen not a peep
well it's a great point and obviously
when the thousands of illegal immigrants
who show up at the border
do so they're not wearing masks they're
certainly not wearing face shields
they're certainly not wearing ppe
they've been in some of the most
unsanitary unhygienic environments
imaginable it's an epidemiological
disaster
and these border agents that passed away
those are line of duty deaths
they put their bodies on the line to
keep this country
safe during a pandemic my organization
america first legal along with the state
of texas
is suing the body administration for
violating their own coveted rules
on our southwest border putting our
communities at risk
for the benefit of illegal aliens now
with respect to the ice issue
i want to be very clear about this these
are criminals
that are being set free 92 percent
of illegal aliens deported by ice last
year
under donald trump had criminal charges
or convictions
when they're slashing deportations
that's gang members
that's felons that's people guilty
of sex crimes going free
and then on top of that you have uscis
actively planning to get rid of gang
screening for green cards
something that we were working on now
they're getting rid of by the way i've
seen
the draft documents showing them trying
to get rid
of that screening question that's
outrageous
congressman you know when stephen was in
the trump white house and i know you
followed this obviously as well
being an active congressman on the issue
we had largely not fixed i mean the
problem was never solved at the barter
but but the trump administration
had done yeoman's work in in getting a
hold of that southern border
i mean really you have to be a democrat
to create
a problem for a solution we've already
this problem was being fixed remain in
mexico
the other you know the asylum the affix
to the asylum rules
and they screwed this thing up i mean
this is absurd
yeah that's exactly right dan president
trump inherited a problem and
solved it and they uh biden
administration uh inherited a solution
and have
totally botched it up and it is
everything you say everything from
stopping the fence to providing
dollars to illegal aliens who come
across to stopping
the mexico city uh she may remain in
mexico policy
the the agreement with the northern
triangle states and you know what
uh now this this this not surprising
that they're talking about
emasculating ice even further but
steven's exactly right these are
criminals that ice goes after
they're the ones who need to be removed
from the country more than anybody else
to keep this country safe and the biden
administration
they won't even acknowledge this don't
forget secretary mayor has just said
this week
the border is closed well when i was
down to the border just a couple of days
ago
it was a steady stream of people coming
across and surrendering
and that was in a sector the yuma sector
and this is
everywhere along the border they're not
doing enough in fact they're not doing
anything because i do truly believe
you can't be this incompetent they have
to desire this they wanted and
campaigned for open borders that's what
this looks like
yeah stephen you said something on an
appearance on this network the other
night i was watching
forgive me i don't remember the show but
you said something that really got under
my skin
um you said you know it's amazing these
hotels
were spending tens of millions um to to
to house
people in the country illegally not
illegally
and you brought up the point you know we
have homeless veterans out there fought
for this country
we have american citizens with
psychological problems on the street
and we're spending tens of millions of
dollars to shield people who could have
come here legally and said no i don't
think so we're just going to disregard
the law
and do what we want you know when
president trump ran for office he used
to say
we treat illegal aliens in this country
better than veterans
when he got elected he switched that put
our veterans
first and secured our border we are now
literally living in a time
it is not hyperbole it is fact that we
have
homeless veterans and we have a
president
who is using taxpayer dollars to house
illegal aliens
next time you see a veteran on the
street who needs help who needs
a path forward a path upward just
remember your tax dollars are going
to help somebody who has been in this
country for hours in violation
of our laws to take american jobs and
american benefits
it is a thunderous violation of the
social contract
yeah hey thanks guys i really appreciate
it great commentary
coming up hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else